the reason why I can retire now and be
completely comfortable about it because
I know that I've done everything I could
to be the best basketball player I could
be unfortunately unfortunately I felt
quite a bit okay you know but I
understand that's actually part of the
process of succeeding you got worked on
pull up jump shot going left I can see
the results that night right and the
business world is different
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from one of the
greatest basketball players of all time
mr. Kobe Bryant and my take on his top
ten rules for success volume two rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick for
yourself as well enjoy
follow your passion first first first
first first first when I retired from
the game I said they're asking kind of
all the wrong questions it was the
biggest industry I can get into and it's
all the wrong stuff and you got to sit
there and ask yourself okay what am I
truly passionate about what do I enjoy
doing and when you feel that way
honestly I mean you feel like you have
never worked a day in your life it's the
most fun thing in the world you get up
in the morning excited about what you're
doing and you got to be really honest
with yourself about it
if you wake up in the morning and you're
dreading going to work dude do something
else do something else and those are
hard decisions to make but when you make
those decisions it's a very liberating
experience and you'll find out that the
rewards will come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you've mentioned that you you've been
lucky enough to have mentors in your
life such as Anna Wintour the editor of
Vogue Arianna Huffington
Johnny I've of Apple I'm notorious for
just cold calling people in I just pick
up the phone call them up and let's just
talk you know there's nothing in
particular I just want to talk and just
you know explain to me how you see your
business you know how do you operate the
business you know Johnny Ives in
particular me is just fascinating his
process of creating design and when I
was playing I used what I did that I
used to try to connect the dots between
how John Williams will compose a score
for a film or Johnny eyes would design
new Apple product and how does that
connect to how I play the game of
basketball is there's something there
that I can learn that can be used when I
step out here on the court there's
lessons that surround us I mean it life
is basically a library just it you know
all we need to do is just open our eyes
and look and and ask and read
accordingly so is that something you
were doing you of building those
relationships even but outside of your
interest as a businessman really even as
an athlete and a basketball player yeah
I mean it's the curiosity I think the
curiosity is the most important thing I
mean it's it's you know it's sounds
really weird to say but it means like
leadership lessons yeah I learn
leadership lessons just from walking in
the park is just observing nature and
the sons relationship with nature and
relationship with the moon and the Sun
understanding when to be present and
when they go away right because as a
teammate it was like dude the sun's out
all damn long you're gonna sunburn a
hell of a lot of people right so if I'm
playing this game and I'm on top of my
guys for 48 minutes dude you're gonna
sunburn every single team made there
right so the certain times was important
from sudden to be president sometimes it
needs to go away right and but their
life lessons that surround us at all
times and I've always been extremely
extremely curious about those things
[Music]
[Applause]
just place
behind-the-back two-spirit
[Applause]
show me some I've been with you for a
long way the one moment that stands out
out of we've done I don't know how many
that we've done the what eight hundred
events the one time was 4:00 a.m. we
went up to practice at 4:00 a.m. and
that was your idea to do it well then
you know all these Nike people are like
no no no no let's not let's not do that
and then you're like let's do it at 4:00
a.m. so you got security you got brand
marketing sports marketing go no no no
no no no that's not good you're like
let's do it because that's your
sustenance right I mean to me it just
makes complete sense not to us see we
all right what you usually I'm sleeping
at 4:00 a.m. you're you're working out I
like about that okay so if if your job
is to try to be the best basketball
player you can be okay to do that you
have to practice you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can so if you get up at
10:00 in the morning train at 11:00
12:00 say 12:00 train at 12:00 train for
two hours 12:00 to 2:00 you have to let
your body recover so you eat recover
whatever you get back out you train
start training it at 6:00 train from
6:00 to 8:00 right and now you go home
and shower you dinner you go to bed you
wake up do it again right those are two
sessions all right now imagine you wake
up at 3:00 you train at 4:00 you go 4 to
6 come home
breakfast relax so so now you're back at
it again 9 to 11 right relax and now
just on your back at it again to the 4
and have you're back at it again
you know 7 to 9 look how much more
training I have done by simply starting
at 4
all right so now you do that and as the
years go on the separation that you have
with your competitors and your peers
just grows larger and larger and larger
and larger and larger and by year five
or six doesn't matter what kind of work
they're doing a summer they're never
going to catch up because they're five
years behind so it makes sense to get up
and start your day early because you can
get more work out is that genetic or is
that something you you engrained and
trained yourself no it was just you that
for me it was it was just common sense
like it
and okay if I start earlier I can train
more hours and I know the other guys
aren't doing it because I know what
their training schedule is right so I
know if I do this consistently over time
it's the gaps just gonna widen and why
no why no why no why and they won't be
able to get that back mm-hmm
so it's me it was just common sense I'm
like thinking how can I get an advantage
Oh start earlier yeah let's do that
how do you how do you develop that or
where do you what do you learn that from
well I I think it's just no it's just a
matter of what's important to you mm-hmm
what's important to you for whatever
reason you know I felt like I didn't
feel good about myself if I wasn't doing
everything I could to be the best
version of myself if I felt like I left
anything on the table
it would eat away at me I wouldn't be
able to look myself in the mirror right
so the reason why I can retire now and
be completely comfortable about it
because I know that I've done everything
I could to be the best basketball player
I could be and so that's where it comes
from for me you can't leave any stone
unturned
[Music]
[Applause]
when you think about your risk tolerance
for failure how far are you willing to
fail well I mean unfortunately
unfortunately I felt quite a bit yeah
you know but I understand that's
actually part of the process of
succeeding I'm not one that really
believe in failure I believe you have
setbacks and you know you have to learn
from those you have to learn what are
those landmines that can be avoided the
next time
what are those pitfalls you have to
learn from that stuff so you know
welcome those things it's a part of life
but are you prepared to like really fail
it's something totally new like what if
you're just a VC then I wish you see
yeah you know and then I work at it and
then I'm not as you see the next yeah
you know whenever it happens yeah
listen aya my first year in league on
national TV 18 years old got shot five
straight air balls in the playoffs in
front of millions of people yeah I think
my time is pretty high yeah yeah I think
I'm alright right
[Music]
as the shots Davidson when you play a
game or you train you see immediate
results right you see that right there
you know I worked on pull-up jump shot
going left I can see the results that
night right
and the business world is different you
know you have to have the patience you
have to find beauty in the process of
building something to find beauty in the
journey and understand that the end
result it's not really the most
beautiful part of it so it's having that
patience
[Music]
sir
why here he does a great job going in
over the to seminar the passion came
from the love for the game you know I
loved everything about it like the smell
of the ball you love the smell of the
ball yes the ball you know the smell of
like brand-new sneakers and like the
sound the ball mates when it hits the
ground sneakers in the gym yeah the ball
going through the net like all those
things I love and so the passion comes
from that because once you have that
love you just want to be a part of this
thing all the time
is there one moment where you can say it
defined your passion for basketball is
their story or moment when you said that
wasn't it that was it that was like when
I felt really passionate no I
it doesn't never leave never leaves like
that you know the game was just a part
of me so it never leaves even now that
I'm retired you know everything I've
learned from the game of basketball
carried it over into life you know like
basketballs helped me be a better person
a better friend but how solid well
because there's life lessons that are
within the game like communications like
unselfishness my attention to detail and
empathy and compassion like all those
things are in the game and as an athlete
if we are aware of those things it helps
us become better human human beings and
you can apply that toward your post post
basketball game retirement into your
business world surely true ventures sure
I mean you can play you know I was
applying that even when I was playing
just in life outside of the game and
even more so now you know I'm building a
business and all these things you know
kind of culture you when I have all
those things are or directly
learn from the game of basketball
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
and you're my achilles and it became
something worse okay this is this is the
end of my career could be now so since I
was 21 years old and thinking okay I
have to figure out what comes next
you kind of brainstorm uid aid but you
never really executed and when the
injury happened is I okay no I needed to
start building now right and that's when
the turning point was for me but I'm
sitting there and I have you kilise
injury it's it's one thing to sit there
and try to block out the frustrations
and being injured because that's you're
constantly tugging but that right as
opposed to simply replacing that with a
new challenge that's something that gets
you excited so now you're not focused on
not being depressed you're focused on
the excitement of building something and
so it was extremely exciting man having
to figure something out and build it
from the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Koby Inc in this venture capital from
her a lot to take on
are there other other things it seems
like kind of each of your vehicles maybe
has a specific purpose are there other
areas and things that you're looking at
and want to pursue it spacing right
because you know we have there's certain
things that we want to get to but we
have to pace those out because we have
to have absolute focus on a few of those
things right Brian stipple fun and the
stories that we are creating right those
are two lenses right now there are other
things that are going to come but that's
way down the road you know we have to
have a very very sharp winds because we
can't do so many things now that's the
hardest part when we first started it is
you have so many people coming from
different different angles different
points of view and you can do this you
can do that and you know it's a lot of
them are very lucrative offers but their
small window my opportunities and the
hardest parts been pushing those to the
side and going for things that have a
much much longer tail which is risky but
you know what are you gonna do I think
that's the best way to go about it
[Music]
Paterson
[Music]
you want to be known long-term as Kobe
Bryant the storyteller and
businessperson who happen to be a
basketball player or the basketball
player who had a successful career
thereafter know it depends who you talk
to if I'm talking to you well I'm saying
if you ask that question to a writer
who's never seen a basketball game
before I would love to be known as the
kick-ass storyteller all right if you
talk to an athlete that doesn't like
reading a book for anything and I'd like
to be known as a phenomenal basketball
player right personally I would love to
be both because I am both alright you
can't shelf one for the other
I mean the game has brought me to where
I am today you know the investment
platform the Bryan style platform the
storytelling that we're doing is going
to put me where I will be 20 years from
now we really want to create something
that is epic and the patient's making
sure every detail is cared for making
sure you're hitting the proper beats
from a plot perspective all right you
know the patient's the detail
[Music]
in the trial
I have decided to skip college and take
my talents to a VA a team what about
individual he's got one more chat
[Music]
so you could take that to the bank it is
anybody who asks
[Music]
[ __ ] doesn't change it just kind of
evolves you promise me one thing
what's up I've made 50 what you guys
learn from about your team from this
series and how's it going to help you
improve moving on in this place holders
in a part-time job you guys for all
those you [ __ ] whatever do you think you
think you guys deserve all the beating
that's took in the media a lot of times
writers when they write stuff like that
means they care there Laker fans anyway
so we have to get better you have to get
better at playing together you have to
do better than spacing Africa better at
ball Jesus Christ can't believe I'm
saying to you at all that just being
late to the press play on tape no no
notnot for long another budget idiots
remember when Kobe Bryant used to dunk
and it wasn't a surprise every time he
dunks it's a big deal
season but here's some vintage Kobe and
even I thought he's gonna pull up here
but he rips through barns and goes to
the
[Applause]
[Music]
to stop it
13 and
[Applause]
chuckles [ __ ]
[Applause]
I think it's the technical because the
bids of the Lakers
to the floor you take a look Chris Rock
sitting right next to Kobe Bryant
shooting the breeze funniest man in the
world telling jokes and take a look at
Kobe Bryant
I don't even hear you
[Music]
[Applause]
my mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they'd love to get it into Nash's hand
and they do
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because satvinder combi
asked me to if there's someone you like
me to cover in a future top ten check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video what
lesson really hit home the hardest what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Roberto
Blake Roberto thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book here one
word I'm doing the interview on your
channel and being one of the people that
we profiled in the book I really
appreciate all your support around my
book launch and I hope you enjoy the
read I'm in the book you're one word by
my good friend Evan Carmichael thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon
what are the skills that you think best
translate that you that you learned and
picked up and built over the years to
what you want to do now and what are the
areas that maybe are a little more
frightening to you as muscles that you
feel you have to develop well I think
it's the communication and the working
with groups of people that's always the
most important thing that's how you win
championships when you take guys of a
team that have completely different
backgrounds and from different parts of
the world different religious beliefs
different political beliefs and you put
them all on one team and say ok you guys
have to get on the same page and figure
out how to win a championship right so
figuring out how to navigate that and
how to speak to the whole while speaking
to individuals is I think the thing that
carries over the most into the business
world if you making it up if you take a
kid for example that is tall and
extremely lanky right it's very
uncomfortable with this height 12 years
old
uncomfortable walks around school
shoulders slouched because they're not
comfortable in their skin right right
now you move them to the basketball
court where now they don't want to play
the pose because they think it's not
cool to play the pose anymore they're on
the wing just saying so all the kids are
playing the perimeter right and so how
you connect how do you connect that
story to human nature right I have no
idea so if you take the kid in through
sport you teach the kid how to play the
post you teach them that there's beauty
in playing a pose what you're saying to
the kid is that there's a beauty in
being who you are there's beauty and
playing To Your Strengths so now through
the sport when the kids walking down
that hallway in school he's not
slouching his shoulders anymore right
just comfortable with who he is he's
accepting who he is and you can
absolutely do that through sport
once upon a time there was a young
basketball player who had dreams of
becoming one of the greatest basketball
players of all time what 17 years old or
the hunger motivation and a desire to be
the best possible basketball player got
to be he worked day and night every day
for years and years and years and years
and years as time went on 20 years had
passed he felt that he had accomplished
all that he set out to accomplish but
would he come to realize is that the
goal that he set out initially to
becoming the greatest of all time was a
very fickle one I really realized that
the most important thing in life is how
your career moves and touches those
around you and how it carries forward to
the next generation
but he realize that's what makes true
greatness the story would be about
transformation of a kid looking inwardly
to then growing up and understand any
importance in the powers with it out
it's a great feeling to know that you're
set a goal for yourself
anyway able to be stackable let's not do
that if I the power to turn back time I
wouldn't never use it
think about it because then every moment
that you go through means absolutely
nothing because you can always go back
and do it again so it loses its flavor
it's it's loses its its beauty when
things are final and you know moments
won't ever come again to be able to have
the power to go back and experience
those things is it's silly to me when
you think that your time very at peace
with it and I'm very thankful you know
for the for the 20 years that I've had
and
[Music]
ready to go
[Music]
one would see was one long me down the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]